est-il vraiment surprenant que l'
homme le plus puissant du monde soit une
figure de controverse nous, en tant que population
sur cette planète, cherchions un
sauveur nous parlons d'un milliard
dont l'existence même ne nous dit pas
la vérité défie la nôtre  sens de la
priorité dans l'univers les êtres humains
ont un bilan horrible de la France qui
suit des gens avec un grand pouvoir un
pouvoir absolu corrompt absolument hé
peut-être qu'il est juste un gars qui essaie de faire le
bon petit mieux maintenant les démons
delgada ne viennent pas de l'enfer sous un autre
guerrier  ils viennent du ciel le monde
a été tellement rattrapé par ce qu'il peut
faire que personne n'a demandé ce qu'il devait
c'est comme ça que ça déclenche la fièvre la rage
le sentiment d'impuissance mais tourne les
bons hommes
cruels
dis moi tu as joué
tu veux
tu
vous